en palestina la guerra de ucrania no
deja indiferente a la población ni a las
autoridades quienes sienten cierta
amargura algunos consideran que mientras
la comunidad internacional denunció fue
realmente la guerra e impuso sanciones
fuertes contra rusia otros conflictos y
crímenes fueron ignorados algo que
criticó al presidente de la autoridad
palestina mahmud abbas el domingo
durante su reunión con el secretario de
estado estadounidense anthony blinken
a pesar de los crímenes de la ocupación
israelí que equivalen a una limpieza
étnica y a una discriminación racial no
encontramos a nadie que responsabiliza a
israel por su comportamiento como estado
por encima de la ley
en su reporte global sobre el año 2021
la organización human rights watch
denunció la represión en contra de los
palestinos por el estado judío así como
la política del gobierno israelí de
mantener la dominación sobre ellos la
ong afirmó que estas acciones
constituyen crímenes contra la humanidad
de apartheid y persecución los
palestinos también denuncian el doble
rasero de las redes sociales que con
frecuencia censuran sus críticas a
israel mientras dan una especial margen
a los ucranianos para expresar sus
posiciones contra rusia la máquina no
ejecutó cuando eliminado en mis
publicaciones o reducían el alcance de
mis historias sentía que ni siquiera
tenía los derechos básicos de libertad
de opinión no tenía libertad de
expresión
y no lo diferente también otra señal del
aislamiento de palestina fue la cumbre
del néguev en la que participaron israel
eeuu y varios países árabes pero a la
que para lesiona no fue invitada